se nos dice en cuántos puntos las
gráficas de las funciones de igual a
cero de teta y la coseno de teta se
intersectan para valores de teta entre 0
y 20 es menor o igual que teta y teta es
menor o igual que 2 vías y que vamos a
incluir los extremos y para hacer esto
hice yo una tabla una tabla para teta
coseno de teta y seno de teta la cual
podemos usar junto con el círculo
unitario y así bueno de manera efectiva
y rápida graficar las funciones de
igualación ett iguala coseno de teta
luego podemos pensar en cuántas veces se
intersectan y donde se intersectan así
que vamos a iniciar con esto este es el
círculo unitario y aquí tiene el eje de
las este es el eje de las x este es el
eje de las leyes y bueno vamos a
graficar las dos funciones este será el
eje de las 'íes' y este es el eje bueno
es una función con respecto a teta así
que primero pensemos en qué pasa cuando
teta es igual a 0 cuando ted es igual a
0 estamos en en este punto del círculo
unitario aquí y qué coordenada es ésta
esto es la coordenada
10 así que bueno es la coordenada es la
coordenada 10 y que es co 0 de teta
cuándo teta es igual a 0 costello la
teta cuanto teta es igual a 0 es 1 ajá
este es uno y cero de teta cuando teta
es igual a cero es cero
esta es la coordenada de las equis en el
punto de intersección con el círculo
unitario y esta es la coordenada de la
siesta este es el de las equis y este es
el de las 'íes' entonces sigamos qué
pasa con pi sobre dos en piso pero dos
nos ubicamos aquí qué coordenadas esa es
x igual a cero y igual a uno ahora
basándonos en eso
costello de teta es igual a cero y seno
de treinta es igual a uno la coordenada
de las diez así que bueno vamos a
ubicarnos aquí es cero y uno ahora nos
ubicamos en pi estamos en este punto del
círculo unitario cuál es la coordenada
correspondiente es menos 10 menos 10 y
que es coste no detecta en este caso es
la coordenada x entonces menos 1
y sino de tratar será la coordenada de
leyes la cual es cero así que sigamos
ahora estamos acá abajo en tres pisos
sobre dos ya recorrimos todo esto y
bueno qué coordenadas está está esa
coordenada 0 - 1
por lo tanto coseno de teta es la
coordenada es la coordenada con respecto
a x con 0 de teta será igual a 0 y 0 de
teta será igual a menos 1 así que menos
uno y finalmente regresamos a 2 pib ya
es una revolución ya completamos ya
dimos toda la vuelta así que regresamos
a este punto entonces está coordenada es
la misma que en el caso de cero radiales
así que cocinó de teta es 1 en este caso
y seno de teta es igual a 0
así que 1 y 0 y ya con esto podemos
hacer la gráfica y pensar en donde
pueden interceptarse así que primero
hagamos para la función con zero de teta
cuando teta es igual a 0 cuando te está
bueno de aquí esto es 1
este punto es menos 1 así que ok ya
iguala coseno de teta teta es igual a 0
jose no detecta es igual a 1
entonces cuando teta es igual ahora
cuando te ves igual a pi sobre dos coste
no de teta como puedes ver es cero y
después cuando te estás igual a pi coste
930 es igual a menos uno cuando teta es
igual a tres pisos de dos coste no de
teta es igual a cero y finalmente
finalmente cuando teta es igual a dos pi
coste no de teta es igual a uno y la
curva la curva se mirará algo así
algo así hago hago el mejor intento por
dibujarla
entonces se mira se mira la curva así
para la gráfica para la función coseno
de teta ahora ahora bueno ya hagamos lo
mismo vamos a hacer así se va a mirar
para igual a coseno de teta
ahora hagamos lo mismo para la función
seno de teta
cuando t3 igual a cero seno de teta es
igual a cero cuando te está es igual a
ti sobre dos seno de 30 es igual a 1
cuando te quedes igual api seno de teta
es igual a cero cuando usted está es
igual a 3 bis sobre 2 seno de teta es
igual a menos 1 cuando te estás
igualados pi seno de teta es igual a
cero por lo tanto la gráfica la gráfica
se mira algo algo de este estilo
así se ve la curva
luego llega aquí suben
y bueno solo visualmente podemos
responder a la pregunta en cuántos
puntos las gráficas igual a seno de teta
y lacoste no de teta se intersectan en
el intervalo para teta entre 0 y 2
incluyendo incluyendo los puntos los
extremos bueno simplemente observando la
gráfica hay dos puntos de intersección
estos dos y solamente en el intervalo de
0 a 2 pi ahora son gráficas cíclicas así
que seguirán interceptándose pero sólo
en este intervalo se intersecta dos
veces así que pensemos en qué puntos qué
valor tienen estos puntos porque tal
parece que están justo justo entre cero
y pi sobre dos así que entre cero y pi
sobre dos ahí tenemos una intersección y
también acá entre pi y tres pisos de dos
así que observando nuestro círculo
unitario vemos si podemos bueno hay que
ver hay que ver si podemos averiguar qué
valores son estos parece que este punto
este punto aquí es pi sobre 4
y cuartos
entonces voy a poner aquí es un ángulo
de 45 grados y voy a poner acá y sobre 4
ahora qué punto es este qué coordenadas
tiene este punto aquí hay un un
triángulo rectángulo así que bueno que
sabemos sobre triángulos rectángulos lo
voy a dibujar acá abajo para que quede
más claro lo que estoy diciendo es bueno
familiarizarse con los triángulos
rectángulos aunque de hecho son muy
familiares están en todas partes hago el
mejor intento de dibujar este triángulo
rectángulo aquí tiene su ángulo rector
este ángulo mide 45 grados pero cuánto
mide la hipotenusa como es un círculo
unitario tiene radio 1 así que la
hipotenusa mide 1 y este ángulo cuánto
mide como bueno también mide 45 grados
porque la suma de los ángulos internos
de un triángulo es de 180 y cómo estos
ángulos miden lo mismo también estos dos
lados este lado es igual a este lado y
ahora con esto ya podemos usar el
famosísimo teorema de pitágoras así que
vamos a usarlo
en cuenta que estos sus lados son
iguales supongamos llamemos a este
digamos que la longitud de este lado es
am así que este lado también te de
longitud am y usando el teorema de
pitágoras podemos decir que al cuadrado
más al cuadrado es igual a 1 o que 2 al
cuadrado es igual a 1 por lo tanto al
cuadrado es igual a un medio así que a
es igual a 1 sobre raíz de dos ahora
podemos racionalizar el denominador
multiplicamos por raíz de dos sobre raíz
de dos y nos queda an es igual uno por
rais de 12 raíz de 2 y raíz de dos por
raíz de 2 éstos así que a es igual a
raíz de dos sobre 2 este lado mide raíz
de dos sobre 2 es también y de eso así
que la base del triángulo mide raíz de 2
sobre 2 y la altura del triángulo
también mide raíz de 2 sobre dos así que
basándonos en esto que coordenada
corresponde a ese punto es raíz de 2
esto es raíz de 2 sobre 2
así que eso es x raíz de 2 sobre 2 y la
coordenada jr también es raíz de 2 sobre
2 como puedes ver aquí así que es raíz
de 2 sobre 2
y entonces coseno detectan es la
coordenada x así que es raíz de 2 sobre
29 tratas de la coordenada y raíz de 2
sobre 2 puedes ver inmediatamente que en
efecto son iguales en ese punto
en este punto ambos son igual a raíz de
dos sobre dos coma raíz de dos sobre dos
ahora que hay de este punto parece que
está entre pi y tres piso sobre dos
entonces como puedes ver aquí este este
es el punto que estamos buscando justo
aquí el cual corresponde a ti sobre
cuatro más para entonces primas y sobre
cuatro lo cual es lo mismo que cuatro
pisos sobre cuatro más y sobre cuatro
entonces esto este es el punto cinco
sobre cuatro aquí está cinco piso sobre
cuatro es igual a 5 y sobre 4 estamos
buscando para el valor theta igual a 5
pi sobre 4 y hay muchas maneras de
pensar en esto
y bueno pues podemos usar geometría es
lo bueno veamos si este ángulo mide 45
también este mide 45 entonces podemos
hacer algo similar podemos dibujar un
triángulo rectángulo
y la hipotenusa mide 1 este ángulo es un
ángulo recto y este ángulo mide 45
también este ángulo mide 45 y como
puedes ver son triángulos congruentes
los lados miden lo mismo así que así que
este lado del triángulo este lado mide
raíz de 2 sobre 2 y también este raíz de
2 sobre 2
ahora vamos a usar la misma lógica que
usamos acá basándonos en eso cual esa
coordenada para este punto pensemos en
el valor para x es de raíz de 2 sobre 2
en la dirección negativa así que es raíz
de 2 sobre 2 hacia la izquierda desde el
origen entonces es menos raíz de 2 sobre
2 este punto es el que el que
corresponde en la en el eje de las x es
menos raíz de 2 sobre 2 ahora para las
10 también es raíz de 2 sobre 2 pero
hacia abajo así que
es menos raíz de dos sobre dos con seno
de teta es por lo tanto menos raíz de
dos sobre dos y seno de teta es también
menos raíz de dos sobre dos y ahora
bueno ya podemos ver que en efecto le
les corresponde el mismo valor el mismo
punto así que se intersectan y bueno ya
respondimos a la pregunta a lo que se
nos pedía espero te haya gustado nos
vemos